Let's explore like those who endeavored to travel the sea, ready for action, without hesitation,
to cross the equator, demonstrating their courage. Full of honor, without retreating,
without fainting, let's explore. Neither a storm nor darkness will stop us. With a common goal,
under the blue sky, new directions to follow, without ever thinking of climbing, overcoming
adversity. Let's explore. Full of restlessness, to another latitude. We must sail with a heart
full of hope. When the hurricane rages, we navigate with eagerness. Adventure is a duty in order to be
the first. Let's explore. Let's satisfy our curiosity once again. A brave fighter, the explorer,
always taking a step further, never giving up for the good of humanity. After having already spoken
about so many explorers, you might think that in the second half of the 17th century all the
continents would have been discovered and their maps carefully drawn. No, they were still looking
for the great southern continent, the one that should balance the great land mass. Do you
remember them? That continent exists, Surchals. It is your task as First Lord of the Admiralty
to organize an expedition. Yes, the French have sent Monsieur Bougainville to discover that
continent. We will have to do that too. But to lead that expedition it would take an exceptional
man. Mr. Darling Pell. I am a geographer, a member of the Royal Society. I am an officer,
as you know, I have sailed all the seas. And I am Earl of Northampton. I am prepared to finance
the expedition if I lead it. Of course, gentlemen, the chosen one must have shown proof of being a
good sailor, having mathematical and geographical gifts, as well as knowing how to draw maps and
possessing unparalleled courage. I lean towards James Cook. Send him in. I am James Cook. But his
parents are peasants. He has not even been to university. This man is only a petty officer.
Hmm. Mr. Cook, I know you come from a family of fashion designers, but I value your merits,
knowledge, and courage. I promote you to lieutenant. What kind of ship do you need for
this expedition? A small vessel with a shallow draft to navigate in shallow waters, large and
spacious to carry scientific material and provisions for two years. An airplane, in short,
very sturdy. I see. And do you know of any ships like that? Yes, sir, the coalers. A ship for
transporting coal would be unworthy of a royal expedition. I will not embark. Hem. Yes. Why not,
Mr. Cook. I should have thought of that. I place at your disposal, Lieutenant Charles Clerk.
Your mission will be to make astronomical observations, but you will also be able to
take possession of some lands in the name of her gracious majesty. Mr. Clerk. Truss. Ah,
but how clumsy. This is the ship I was telling you about, Mr. Clerk. It will need some repairs,
complete cleaning, reinforcement of the hull, installation of cabins and anti-Termis treatment.
We will also fit some light portable guns. The mast, which is very long, will have to be replaced,
And consequently the sails too
34,000 pounds of bread
10,000 of flour
100 gallons of beer
7,000 pounds of pork
And 7,000 pounds of sauerkraut
7,000 pounds
You must like sauerkraut, Captain
Sauerkraut, Mr. Clerk
Protects against scurvy
The sailor's disease
This is Mr. Joseph B
Naturalist to the Royal Society
Welcome
I am accompanied, of course
By other attendants
A botanist
A droughtsman
My scientific secretary
My servants
My baggage and my dogs
That is all
Are you sure? It is useless for me to tell you that this is the astronomer, Mr. Greck.
And finally, a goat to provide fresh milk for the officers.
Nick, come aboard.
Well, we are off. I think that is all.
If you only knew how eager I was to go on this voyage.
Hey, watch out for that animal.
Ah, after a year of travel the crew took a well-deserved rest in Tahiti,
where Bugville had been the previous year.
Now heading south we will see if that famous continent exists or not.
If that continent does exist, it must be well hidden.
Land. Very good. I will show you, you bunch of savages. No, stay still. They think we have bad
intentions. We are not going to take advantage of the superiority that weapons give us. Look,
get on board. Since you like weapons, fire a cannon, but do it in the air.
Cook rounded New Zealand and headed towards Tasmania. Captain, we have sighted land there.
It may be the new continent. No, my friend, according to my calculations,
it must be Holland again. Today we call it Australia. We must find a safe bay. Let's head
north. Oh, look at that. I have never seen anything like it. How wonderful. These plants are unknown.
Oh, ah, question mark. It's a duck with four legs. Oh, I like those four legs. Nice collection.
From now on we'll call this the new botany. This is where, 20 years later, some convicts that
England wanted to get rid of founded the city of Sydney. Do you see this? It's fire. They're
definitely Odentots. How interesting. Let's go. They're peaceful people. They live in harmony and
are happy. Let's not bother them. Come on. Hurry up. This looks dangerous. 30 meters 29. Careful,
captain. It's shallow. 10 meters now new. Drop anchor. Lower sails. Thank goodness. Longboats
in the water. Oh, look. Coral shoals as sharp as knives. We've hit a reef. The hull's breached.
pumps quickly, longboats in the water, raise anchors, anchors in the water, go ahead, we're,
not making any progress, we have to lighten the ship, the tide is coming in, we should take in
anchors, but, no, it's not enough yet, the yards, the masts, this is a boss, it's, going to be high
tide tonight at 10, stand by, now, all hands on deck, there's still water coming into the ship,
Captain, we've got to plug the leak. Come on. One, two, three into the water.
Quiet Cove. We'll follow you. If this hadn't plugged the hole, we'd be lost.
It'll take at least two months to get the ship repaired and ready to sail. Let's get to work.
Oh, I'll have time to collect samples. We wish to see Lord Sandwich,
the first Lord of the Admiralty. His Excellency is very busy.
Go and tell him Captain Cook is here.
Captain Cook and Lieutenant Clerk.
Ah, Captain Cook. I still remember the memorable reception His Gracious Majesty gave you on your return from your voyage. It was splendid. You proved that this continent doesn't exist, but you also talked about a way to the Atlantic through the North Pacific.
The Northwest Passage.
The truth is, we would need an experienced captain to explore that passage. Can you think of anyone, Cook?
If you wish, I can go, Your Excellency. Me too.
Well, well, I did not dare to propose it, Captain Cook. Since you wish it, I promote you to commander in the Royal Navy and you, clerk, to captain. Stay, gentlemen. I will order sandwiches.
Sandwiches, Lord Sandwich.
Yes, it is my invention. Do you allow us to eat lunch while working? A good invention, these sandwiches. That's it. He discovered the Hawaiian Islands.
Two large islands. What shall we call them? The Sandwich Islands, of course. In honor of the First Lord.
The god El is long gone, but one day he will return and that day he will bring us prosperity.
Quick, come. There are enormous temples floating in the sea. He takes you for a god. It is.
Better that way they will help us to get supplies. We must reach the north by early summer.
Lower the sails.
Captain, water is coming in. The hold is flooding. The pumps are coming in fast.
And now we have to find a place to repair it. No, this is not the passage.
We've tried many times. Let's continue north. This should be the Bering Strait that was discovered
50 years ago. To the left is Asia and to the right is America. We are in Asia. We will continue
northeast. If there is a passage, it must be around here. Must have passed the Arctic Circle.
What is behind that wall of ice? Big. Get on the mast. No passage. No passage. I was afraid so.
We will follow the coast to the east. It is midnight. But in this region there are no summer
nights. Let's go to sleep. Captain, Captain. What is happening? The ice is closing in. Captain,
if we continue, we will not be able to move. I'm coming. We have to free the ships. Everyone get
to work. Thank goodness. Done. A little more in case we get stuck. Now we will skirt the coast
of Siberia to the west. There may be a passage to Europe. Come up and see. Completely blocked.
There's ice everywhere. We'll return to the Sandwich Islands. We'll try again in the spring.
C. returned to Hawaii, where he was very well received, to arrest his crew.
He didn't know what fate awaited them there.
Maul, there's no doubt about it.
They've chosen you as their god.
Listen, Charles, these people are happy and healthy.
We risk giving them all sorts of diseases against which they have no defenses.
The men have been at sea for a year and they could be tempted by bad things.
We must keep them from going ashore and prevent the natives from coming aboard.
It won't be easy.
They're going to keep us from going ashore.
Only the officers will be allowed to go.
It's not fair. I want to go. Me too. Do you really think he's the god Lono? His men call him Cook,
not Lono. He must go now. Go quickly. There's more and more fighting. I can't keep the men
ashore and I can't arrest them all. So let's go. Lower the sails quickly. We had to turn back.
We need a tree to make a mast. August a duod. They only allow five men to go ashore, not one
more. That will be enough. I want to avoid the slightest accident. We will return for him
tomorrow morning. They have stolen the new canoe. Thieves, let's take theirs. Why did they do that?
We had welcomed them well. They have stolen our longboat. I will fix this. Um, those savages will
know what I am made of. Don't you dare shoot. Calm down, boys. Be careful with their weapons.
Captain Cook is dead. Revenge. We shoot everyone. Stay. Still, I take command. All aboard. I order
you. Whoever disobeys will be hanged. It was an accident, but we fired first. We should have
prevented that massacre.
Look, may God have mercy on his soul and may the Pacific Ocean he loved so much receive
his body.
Cook left for posterity the first complete map of the Pacific Ocean.
He was the first explorer who sought neither gold nor treasures, only knowledge.
Let's explore the corners of our ever-turning world, finding paths to trace, always taking
a step further, never giving up for the good of humanity.